[موسيقى]
عام على الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه لا
منتصره ولا مهزوم اسلحه وعقوبات قصف ولجوء
تصريحات متبادله لا تتوقف عن التهديد
والوعيد الكل يعد شعبه بالانتصار والعالم
يئن اقتصاديا من تداعيات الحرب ولا اختراق
ولو بسيط على صعيد السلام اسئله تبحث عن
اجابات هل يمكن ان ينتصر احد ومتى وماذا
يدور في عقل بوتين حول القادم ما الذي
تريده واشنطن وماذا ستفعل الصين من يقف
عائقا امام مسار السلام ما الذي سيجري
خلال الفتره القادمه هل ستستخدم اسلحه
مدمره هل يتسع نطاق الحرب من يمتلك
الاجابات الثابت ان الحرب وقعت
[موسيقى]
في اطار متابعتنا الخبريه للحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه اعلن الرئيس البولنديه اندريه
انه نقش مع نظيره الامريكي جو بايدن
امكانيه انتاج مشترك للذخائر لصالح
اوكرانيا وقال دوده ان هذه المحادثات
ستستمر وكان مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بورين اعلن ان دول
الاعضاء ستعتمد على مخزوناتها لتسريع
توريد الاسلحه والذخيره الى اوكرانيا لكن
المخزونات الغربيه تتناقص وبالتالي من
الضروري تجديدها
قال البيت الابيض في تصريح للعربيه ان اي
اتفاق سلام يجب ان ياخذ بعين الاعتبار
سياده اوكرانيا وان المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه لا تشير الى ان الصين بصدد
تقديم دعم عسكري لروسيا اما بشان الدور
الايراني فصرح المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي ان ايران ارسلت لروسيا
قطع دبابات ومدفعيه لاستخدامها في معاركها
باوكرانيا وان واشنطن تعتقد بان روسيا قد
تزود ايران بطائرات مقاتله واضاف ايضا بان
ايران تحاول الحصول على مليارات الدولارات
من روسيا مقابل اعتاد عسكري كما اشار الى
ان مجموعه السبع
ركزت على تكثيف الدعم لاوكرانيا لتنتصر
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني بلينكل
ان دول العالم ستواصل دعمها لاوكرانيا
مضيفا في كلمه له في مجلس الامن ان هذا
الدعم سيمنع فردا نظام عالمي يسيطر فيه
القوي على الضعيف ويسمح بمحو حدود دول
والاستيلاء على دول اخرى حسب وصفه
جميع الدول حول العالم تدعم اوكرانيا
لاننا نقر جميعا باننا لو تخلينا عن
اوكرانيا فنحن بذلك نتخلى عن ميثاق الامم
المتحده بحد ذاته وعن القواعد التي تضمن
امننا جميعا وسلامتنا ان الاستيلاء على
الاراضي بالقوه ومحو حدود دوله اخرى
واستهداف مدنيين في الحروب امور غير مقبول
بها وان لم ننتصر لمبادئنا فهذا سيجعلنا
امام عالم يسيطر فيه القوي على الضعيف وهو
العالم الذي انشئت من اجله هذه المنظمه
بوضع حد له
وينضم لنا في هذه التغطيه من واشنطن عبر
سكايب جون بولتون مستشار الامن القومي
السابق مرحبا بك سيد بولتون في العام
الجديد للحرب ماذا يتوقع مزيد من الحرب
والصراع ام ان مسارا للسلام قد يفتح
اعتقد بان النزاع على الارجح سيستمر ولا
يوجد اي
احتمال في هذه المرحله التي يقول فيها
يقول انه حقق اهدافهم لا اعتقد بانه
السياره اي سبب للتفاوض وكما ان
لا يوجد ايداعي يدفعها
للتفاوض بينما تسيطر روسيا اليوم كان هناك
مقترح سلام صيني
حاسما يسمى
ويقال انه متوازن ولكن بلا شكوى يميل تجاه
مصلحه روسيا ورفضتها الولايات المتحده
ودول غيرها فحتى بعد مضي عامه للنزاعه
اعتقد بان احتمالا او التسعين يوما وربما
حتى اكثر
للاسف سيكون هنالك المزيد من النزاع
هناك اسئله كثيره حول تدور في الفتره
الماضيه حول اصرار واشنطن على الزج بالصين
في هذا الصراع حينما تقول ان هناك
توقعات بان تمد الصين روسيا باسلحه ثم
ياتي البيت الابيض منذ قليل ويقول ان هذا
الامر ليس هناك معلومات استخباراتيه بشان
ما الذي تهدف به او من ورائه واشنطن بهذه
التصريحات
لا استطيع ان اؤكد هذا القول او غيره ولكن
لا اعتقد بان وزير الخارجيه حصل نصيحه
جيده لتحذير كما فعلت في الاسبوع الماضي
من ان
هذه مرحله خطره نمر فيها خاصه مع ايصال
الاسلحه لم تكن لديهم اي معلومات
تدعم روسيا في هذا النزاع منذ البدايه حتى
اشترت المزيد من الغاز والنطل التعويض عن
خسائر المبيعات بسبب العقوبات
والسماحه المؤسسات الماليه
لاموالها عبر منظومه الصين الماليه وربما
حتى في سبل اخرى لتسهيل نقل الاسلحه من
دول اخرى
وصولا الى روسيا لاستخدامها في اوكرانيا
فاعتقدوا بانه
واضح من مقترح السلام الصيني حسب ما يسمى
بان الصين الثقيفه بشكل كبير الى جانبي
بروسيا في هذا النزاع وتعمل كل ما في
وسعها لتحقق روسيا على الانتصار والصينيون
يتوقعون بالمقابل اذا ما تحركوا ضد تايوان
او اي دوله اخرى في منطقه المحيطين
الهادئه والهنديب يتوقعون من روسيا ست لها
لنكن اكثر صراحه ووضوح البعض يعتقد ان هذا
الامر يحمل قدرا من خلط الاوراق ماذا تفعل
الصين محددا في هادئه او تحديدا في هذه
الحرب من وجهه نظري واشنطن هل تدعم روسيا
باسلحه ان تسعى لاقرار سلام حتى ولو كان
قد حمل انحيازا لروسيا لابد ان يكون هناك
تقدير موقف واضح في هذا الامر لان حينما
نتحدث عن روسيا والصين معا اذا نحن بصدد
حرب عالميه وليست حرب في اوكرانيا
هذا هو تعبير الدقيق لما يجري ومهم جدا
يدركه جميع ما يجرين ما تطوره الصين
وروسيا او على قناه السميه
ربما تحالف رسمي حسب قوله الفرنسيين وربما
مثل المحور كما شاهدناه خلال ايام الحرب
البارده ولكن الصين هي الشركه المهيمن هنا
وتتوقع الحصول على سلعه مثل الغاز والنفط
والمعادن ومنتجات الزراعيه من روسيا
والصين بلا شك هي الشركه المهيمن في هذه
العلاقه فهي
حتى
كوريا الشماليه وايران وسرقه بها ولكن هذا
مزيد يشمل طموحات عالميه ما يهددو اوروبا
بشكل مباشر كما حصل عبر هجوم روسيا على
اوكرانيا وربما يهدد وانا عبر هدوم صيني
محتمل وتهدد الشرق الاوسط عبر العلاقات
الايرانيه فهذا تطور خطير جدا في العالم
واعتقد باننا جميعا
انت تعلم جيدا خلال عملك كمستشار وبخبرتك
السياسيه الكبيره ان الحديث الاول في
الدوائر السياسيه الامريكيه كان دوما يحمل
عباره شاينا
شاينا ثم تحول بعد ذلك الى صراع مع بوتين
ما الذي تريده واشنطن لا احد يفهم كيف
ترتب واشنطن الاعداء بالنسبه لها هل هي
روسيا هل الصين ام الاثنين معا
كم
اداره بايدن لديها لبسه فيما يخصه
اولوياتها لا شك في ذلك ولكن اما صالح
الامن القومي الامريكي
تفيدوا باننا يجب ان نوضح بان هذا
الاعتداء
غير الشرعيه ضد اوكرانيا لن يكون مقبولا
في تسعين في عام 1990 لرئيس
الاب بعدان غذاء صدام حسين الكويت رئيس
بوش قال بان هذا الاعتداء الامن يمضي من
دون مساعده
ولن يمر ويجمل فعل شيء مع روسيا وبوتين
وهذا مهم جدا ليس فقط من اجل السلام
والاستقرار في اوروبا بل لدول مثل تايوان
او غيرها بالقرب من الصين وحتى للسلامه
والاستقرار في الشرق الاوسط الذي لا يزال
مهددا من الدعم ايران للارهاب وبرنامج
الاسلحه النووي فهذه مشكله عالميه ومن
المهم جدا ان ناخذ حوارا
في اعلى المستويات
حول التهديد المتزايد تجاهها الاستقرار
العالمي وهذا ما يمثلها هذا الخليط الصيني
الروسي ان تحدثت في هذا الامر عن الحرب في
العراق وتعلم ان التاريخ وجه اتهامات
وتساؤلات واضحه لبوشوا بانهما اخطا في
الحسابات بشان الحرب في العراق هل تعتقد
ان ذاكره سياسيه ستتحدث ايضا عن اخطاء
مشابهه لاداره بايدن في حرب اوكرانيا
الخطا الذي ترتكبه هو عدم توفير ما يكفي
من الدعم لاوكرانيا
وهو طرف بريء تماما هنا اقصد اوكرانيا حيث
غازته روسيا من دون اي سبب او اي داعم ما
عدا
تسهيل ما يرغب من خلال عادتك
تحسباتي بل الامبراطوريه الروسيه لا اعتقد
بان بوتين شيوعي بل هو من الزارات روسيا
او الدول المجاوره لروسيا الدول المستقله
حديثا
استونيا الاتيه والاليتوانيا وغيرها ليس
لها اي رغبه على الاطلاق لان تكون ضمن
الامبراطوريه روسيا مره اخرى
تعرضت لهجوم شديد انت شخصيا حينما اقترحت
تصفيه بوتين في هذه الحرب اذا استخدم
الاسلحه النوويه وحينما قارنت بينه وبين
قاسم سليماني هل مازلت متمسك بنفس الراي
نحن لا نريد ان تستخدموا الاسلحه النوويه
فالسؤال هو ما هو اكثر سبل فعاليه لردع
روسيا من استخدام الاسلحه النوويه في سرعه
اوكرانيا هو قائد القوات المسلحه وهو هدف
عسكري مشروع
يجب ان نوضح من انه هدف وربما ذلك
انتباهها وان كان هناك شخص لديه فكره افضل
لردعي روسيا ومنها من استخدامي السهنوي
فسيسر الاستماع عليه ولكن جذبا انتباهي
بوتين هو افضل سبيل من وجهه نظري
الامن القومي من واشنطن عبر سكايب شكرا لك
شدد وزير الماليه الالماني ان بلاده لن
يكون لديها عمل مع روسيا في الوقت الراهن
ولا في المستقبل ايضا طالما ان الحرب في
اوكرانيا مستمره
لا يمكن ان يكون هناك عمل كالمعتاد مع
روسيا ولم يكون هناك عمل معها في المستقبل
طالما الحرب الروسيه الوحشيه مستمره على
اوكرانيا
هي دبابه سوفيتيه من مخلفات السوفيات
عندما دخلوا برلين وحرروها من النازيين هي
تقف في قلب العاصمه الالمانيه على بعد
امتار قليله فقط من بوابه ومن خلفها مقر
المستشاريه
والبوندستور لم يشكل لوجود هذه الدبابات
هنا جدلا الا بعد ان اندلعت الحرب في
اوكرانيا وبدات المانيا تراجع علاقتها
بروسيا ورغم المطالبات بازاله الدبابات
التي تحولت نصبا تذكريا تعهدت المانيا بعد
خسارتها الحرب بالحفاظ عليها فهي ما زالت
هنا يعكس هذا الجدل الحاله التي تعيشها
المانيا منذ عام والتي تجسدت بازمه دبابات
ليو بارد التي ترددت حكومه المستشار
الاشتراك اولف شولز بتسليمها لكييف
فالاشتراكيون هم من اسسوا لسياسه التقارب
مع الاتحاد السوفيتي في السبعينات
المحلل الالكسي يوسف من معهد فريدريش ابره
المقرب من الاشتراكيين يقول ان هذا جعل من
مراجعه الاشتراكيين لسياستهم مع روسيا
اليوم مهما صعبه ومؤلمه
من الواضح ان العلاقه الخاصه بين المانيا
وروسيا تضررت وهذا مؤلم بالنسبه
للاشتراكيين ولكن ايضا اتخاذ مبادره
عسكريه لا يتماشى مع الثقافه السائده في
برلين المانيا لا تتخذ مبادره عسكريه ورغم
ان الاشتراكيين كانوا هم من اسسوا لسياسه
التقارب مع روسيا فان المستشاره السابقه
لمحافظه انجلميركل اكملتها رئيسه قسم
العلاقات الدوليه في معهد كونراد ادنىور
المقرب من الحزب المسيحي الديمقراطي الذي
تنتمي اليه ماركل تقول ان المانيا كانت
ساذجه في سياستها مع روسيا ولم تستمع
للتحذيرات الكثيره
بعد سقوط الجدار في برلين ظننا ان
بامكاننا بناء امن مشترك مع روسيا ولفتره
طويله اعتقدنا ان بامكاننا العيش اصدقاء
ولكن اكتشفنا متاخرين باننا لا يمكننا
بناء امن مشترك مع روسيا سياسه التقارب
التي يقول الالمان ان الحرب البارده
فرضتها وتاريخ المانيا مع القوه العسكريه
يجعلان برلين تبدو اليوم متردده ولكن من
الواضح بان تاريخ المانيا واشباحه مازالا
يطارضانها راغده بهنام العربيه برلين
من الصعب احصاء الاماكن التي تركز فيها
القسط
دخول داخل الملجا
باني يجب ان نتوجه معهم الى مكان امن
هو ليس اتفاق في الشارع وانه ارتباط على
محطات الوقت
تعاطف كبير مع اللاجئين الاوكرانيين
[موسيقى]
يعد هنا هو رائحه الحرير
هذا مثلا صفاره الانذار اليوم كل ما خرجنا
من وسط العاصمه تزيد حده الاصوات
[موسيقى]
طبعا من يشاهد هذا المنظر يعتقد انه حريق
لهذه البنايات ولكن لكميه الاستهداف
[موسيقى]
وشبكه مراسل العربيه تبقى على الارض في
ميادين الحرب من كراماتور سيكموفد العربيه
احمد بجاتو ومن اسكن راس العربيه عبد
الجواد الرشد ومن شمال دونالدز كموراس
العربيه رائد الاغبر مرحبا بكم الى هذا
الجزء من التغطيه ابدا باحمد به نعلم ان
هناك استعدادات ما تجري في هذه المدينه في
حال اعاده القصف بشكل مكثف كيف تبدو
الصوره لديك احمد
نعم رشا دعينا ان نعرض سريعا على المقالته
القياده العسكريه الاوكرانيه حول الهجمات
خلال هذا اليوم حتى نهايته كانت هناك
محاولات روسيه للتقدم في الجبهات الشرقيه
بالطبع على راسها مناطق ضخمه ولمان هذه
المحاولات تم صدها من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه الموجوده في تلك المناطق كانت
هناك 18 غاره جويه وثلاثين هجوما صاروخيا
استهدفوا كافه الجبهات المختلفه الجنوبيه
والشرقيه كذلك ايضا كانت هناك حاله من فرض
حظر التجوال في المنطقه التي تسيطر عليها
القوات الروسيه في مدينه خرسون
الترجيحات ان ذلك بسبب نقل معدات عسكريه
من شبه جزيره القرم الى هذه المنطقه وهذا
ما ترجحه القياده العسكريه هنا من الناحيه
الاخرى
الرئاسه الاركان الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن انه
تم تنفيذ 14
بطائرات مسيره على مواقع استهدفت فيها
قوات الروسيه الموجوده في الجبهات
المختلفه الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
اسقطت طائره مروحيه وطائره بدون طيار
بالطبع بخموت يعني تشهد ضخمه القريبه من
هنا بالاحرف تشهد اشتباكات قويه ما بين
الجانب الروسي والقوات الاوكرانيه
المتمركزه هناك محاولات مستمره من جانب
القوات الروسيه قوات فيجنر فاجنر تحديدا
لتطويق القوات الموجوده هناك المدينه اشبه
ما تقوم بمدينه اشباح نحو تحدث عن مدينه
كان بها سبعين الف مواطن الان يتواجد بها
من الفين الى ثلاثه الاف مواطن فقط
لا احد يمشي في المدينه وفقا لشهود يعني
اشخاص قدموا من هذه المدينه لا احد يمشي
على الاطلاق المدينه الاشباح اغلب
ايضا من وهي نقطه حيويه ومهمه للغايه مع
زميل رائد الاغبر تفضل رائد
باقي الايام
اكثر من المعتاد اكثر من المعتاد رشا يعني
اصوات الاطلاق النار وذوي الانفجارات لم
يتوقف منذ يعني في الصباح الباكر كانت
وتييرته منخفضه نوعا ما لكن بعد مرور
اليوم وحتى ساعات المساء كانت الوتيره
مرتفعه جدا حتى ان الشوارع كانت خاويه
طيله الوقت اليوم لكن
لنعرج على باقي وهو محور لا اعلم اذا اسود
القسط المهمه مع الزميل ايضا عبد الجواد
الرشد تفضل عبد الجواد
مساء الخير الرشا لك والي الزملاء في
البدايه اسمحي لي بالتعريج حول يعني
التصريح التي خرجت به وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه والذي يتحدث ان موسكو منفتحه على
تحقيق اهداف العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه بالطرق الدبلوماسيه
والسلميه هي خطوه جديده من موسكو نحو
رساله تم ايصالها للغرب بان موسكو جاهزه
للبدء بالمفاوضات وهذا طبعا ما اثار حفيظه
الكثير من المحللين السياسيين في البلاد
الذين بداوا يتحدثون عن هذا الموضوع وعن
ضروره الوصول لطاوله المفاوضات طبعا انا
الان اقف في مدينه ميلز هذا هو مركز
العاصمه طبعا هي عاصمه بيلاروسيا الحليفه
الاستراتيجي الاول والرئيس العسكري
والسياسي لموسكو طبعا هذه المدينه تعيش
حياتها الطبيعيه بشكل طبيعي كما نلاحظ لكن
طبعا لا يمكن اخف حقيقه التوتر الكبير
الحاصل في هذه البلاد طبعا للوضع في
المنطقه من جهه والعقوبات الاقتصاديه التي
طالت هذه البلاد من جهه اخرى طبعا معظم
العقوبات التي طالت موسكو طالت ايضا
بيلاروسيا باعتبارها شريكا لها في كل
المسائل وفي كل الامور لكن طبعا بما يخص
قضيه الشريط الحدودي الطويل والكبير طبعا
هي مسافات طويله بين الاراضي البيلاروسيه
والاوكرانيه والاراضي البيلاروسيه
والبولنديه تشهد توترا كبيرا وتواجدا لعدد
كبير من القوات ان كانت روسيه او
بيلاروسيه حسب تقارير محليه وخارجيه ايضا
العديد من المعدات العسكريه في نقطه مهمه
طبعا رشا هي وهو الاعلان الرسمي من قبل
الاداره السياسيه في بيلاروسيا انه في حال
قامت موسكو بطلب الاراضي البيلاروسيه
والاجواء البيلاروسيه للتقدم نحو الارا ضي
الاوكرانيه فان من ستكون من جديد بمنح هذه
الخطوه
يتجدد الشكر للزميل عبد الجواد الرصد من
مينيسكو وايضا لزميل احمد باجاتو من
اكراماتورسك والزميل رائد الاغبر من دونسك
شكرا على هذه التغطيه المتميزه والمستمره
دائما على شاشه العربيه من الميدان
بعد فشل مساء رئيس الفرنسي في خفض التصعيد
واقناع بوتين بالتراجع عن الحرب في
اوكرانيا اتخذت باريس موقفا اوضح من خلال
دعمها العسكري لاوكرانيا بما دفع سيزر
وانظمه دفاع جوي لكن يبقى السؤال حول حتم
حماسه فرنسا حتى اللحظه في ارسال دبابات
الى اوكرانيا
لم يرغب الرئيس الفرنسي مع بدايه الحرب في
اوكرانيا بقطع الحوار مع روسيا لكن ذلك لم
يفضي الى شيء فظهر تغير في العقيده
العسكريه الفرنسيه ذلك تمثل بان باريس
اصبحت اكثر وضوحا في تموضعها الاقرب الى
كييف بعدما فرنسي قد دعا الى عدم اذلال
روسيا او حتى التفاوض على السلام مع موسكو
لكن ذلك اثار ايضا انتقادات كثيره بالقول
ان الاسلحه التي ترسلها فرنسا الى
اوكرانيا ليست كافيه
فرنسا ترسل الى اوكرانيا الاسلحه التي
تحتاجها اوكرانيا ليست بحاجه لان ترسل
اليها كل الدول طائرات حربيه او مدرعات
عسكريه ودبابات خفيفه او ثقيله كل بلد
عليه تقديمه منظومات الاسلحه المفيده
لاوكرانيا
لكن مع ذلك كان تكييف تامل باستلام دبابات
لوكلير الفرنسيه لكن هذه المساله تبدو
بعيده المنال فوفق مصادر عسكريه فرنسيه
ارسال هذه الدبابات لن يقدم اي قيمه
اضافيه على الارض بل سيعقد التنظيم
العسكري للجيش الاوكراني
فرنسا لن ترسل دبابات لوكلاغ لان هناك
اعداد هائله من الدبابات نحو ثلاثمائه
وخمسين دبابه ستتسلمها اوكرانيا من
الاوروبيين وخصوصا من المانيا وبولندا
لذلك فرنسا ستمصر ارسال انظمه مضاده
للدبابات وسترسل انظمه الدفاع الجوي
المتوسطه المدى محموله من طراز ممبا مع
ايطاليا
هذه الاسلحه التي تقدمها فرنسا وعلى الرغم
من انتقادات حول الكميات الا انها دفعت
باريس الى تسريع وزياده عمليات الانتاج
وهذا الامر اصبح موضع مشاورات منتظمه بين
رؤساء هيئه الاركان في الجيش الفرنسي من
اجل الاستعداد لاي سيناريو قد تفرضه روسيا
في الميدان فادهوك العربيه باريس
وفي اطار تغطيتنا لتداعيات الحرب في
الذكرى الاولى لها ننتقل الى نيويورك
لمتابعه لقاء مراسل العربيه طلال الحاج مع
وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه جيمس كليفرلي
بعد مرور عام على الحرب في اوكرانيا
مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا وسهلا بكم في هذا
اللقاء الحصري مع جيمس وزير الخارجيه
المملكه المتحده الذي يجلس الينا فور
خروجه من قاعه مجلس الامن بعد القاء كلمه
بلاده
خارجيه
شكرا جزيلا يسعدنا
مشاركه لقد خرجت مجلس الامن
قدمت خطابا هاما
المتحدثين الاخرين في المجلس ما هي رساله
الاساسيه من هذه الجلسه لمجلس الامن حول
اوكرانيا التي قدمت للعالم
انحاء العالم وكل قاره على وجه الارض كلهم
تحدثوا عن اهميه
ولكن هذا مهم بل حول هذه المؤسسات التي
حافظت على سلامتنا سمعنا ايضا كلمه
المندوب الروسي
الترحيب بما يسمى خطه السلام الصينيه
لتحقيق السلام في اوكرانيا وقد رحب بها
بينما كان الموقف الماضي مرارا
انهم ليس اعطوا الفاظات ما لم توافق
اوكرانيا
حول الضمائر الاوكرانيه والقرى او
الاستفتاء هل هذه نقطه تحول من روسيا
بلا شك نحن ننظر الى الوثائق التي قدمها
صينيون وهنالك بعض العناصر الهامه ضمنها
مثل معرضين باستخدام النوويه ودعم المتحده
ودائما
ننظر الى هذه الوثيقه بكل جديه وامل
القاده الروسيه اخيرا بدات تدرك الحقيقه
وهي ان العالم يدين تصرفاتهم والعالم
يريدوا ان تنتهي هذه الحرب ويريد ان يرى
اوكرانيا امنه مع حدودها دوليا وامل ان
هذه هي خطوه في الاتجاه المناسب وبكل
صراحه
لازلت غير مقتنع بان بوتين جاده ما يخصها
السلام وكلمه الممثل الروسي
حاول ان يصف
نسخه من التاريخ
يعرفها اي انسان حي ان روسيا بشكل ما هي
المهاجمه او مع العلم ان النساء والاطفال
والرجال اوكرانيين الذين يقتلون بالصواريخ
والقنابل الروسيه
المطالبه
بالانتهاء الفوري للحربي
وسحب روسيا لقواتها من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
هل هذا يشمل القرمي
كما فهمته انت
من وجهه نظري
هذه الاعراض الاوكرانيه هي التي يدافعون
عنها وابنائهم واطفالهم هم الذين يقاتلون
والمصطلح مرارا وتكرارا وهو
ضمن الحدود المعترف بها دوليا
واعتقد بان ما يجب ان تدركه روسيا والعالم
اجمع
لاعاده الرسمه للحدود بالقوه
وهذا يخالف المتحده وهذه المشكله الاكوات
الاوكرانيين في الختام هم هيئه الدوله
والح
الدفاع عن نفسها وهم يجبون يتخذوا هذا
القرار حول الشروط التي سيقبلون بها
بريطانيا وفرنسا
اعضاء في استعطوه لكن كيف ترى تعليقه
كما قلت في كلمه لمجلس الامن
بينما يدركون
اوكرانيا لم تحقق نجاح فسيستخدم كافه
انواع التهديد ولغه التصعيد وتخويفنا
ومنعنا من القيام بالشيء الصحيح وهذا جزء
من استراتيجيته ويجب نتركها كما هي عليه
هي تعبير عن الضعف وليس التعبير عن القوه
لا يوجد اي تهديد لروسيا لا احد يتحدث عن
الاغراض بروسيا ما ان اقوله هو ان روسيا
يجب ان تتوقف المهاجمه اوكرانيا هنالك
تقارير يتم تداولها حول الصين وانها
تفكر بتزويد روسيا بالمساعدات الفتاكه اذا
ما حصلت ذلك فما معنى هذا للحرب في
اوكرانيا
والعلاقات بين الصين
في الحوارات التي خذتها مع الصينيين او
وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
ذكر بانهم يدركان اهميه المتحده كمؤسسه
التصعيد وقد قلت بانني لا اعتقد بانه من
مصلحه الصين ان ننظر له على انها تدعم
نظاما معزولا على المسرح العالمي ولكن ما
اقوله لكافه الدول هو انه لا مصلحه من
تزويد روسيا بمساعده العسكريه فسوف يضر
ذلك بسمعه الدوله وسيكون ذلك هداما واعتقد
بان السلطات الصينيه تدرك ذلك جيدا
بريطانيا هي الثانيه اكبر مانع عسكري
لاوكرانيا بعد الولايات المتحده
لكان تحدثنا عن المؤتمر في لندن لدعم
اوكرانيا
لقد اوضحنا
يجب ان ادعم اوكرانيا الى ان تستعيد
اراضيها
وتعيد
النزاهه اراضيها ولكن حلمه تنتهي الحرب او
ينتهي النزاع في اوكرانيا امنه
ونستطيع اعاده بناء التحتيه فهذا سيكون هو
فحوى المؤتمر في يونيو ليضمن التعاون
الدوليه الذين راحوا على الجانب العسكري
يطابق في اعاده بناء اوكرانيا هل هنالك
رقم تحاول الوصول اليه ليس هناك رقم واضح
لا نعرفه ما هو المبلغ الضروري الى نتعرف
على اجمالي ابرار
العديد من السلوكيات
او الحرس الثوري
فقد الولايات المتحده ضمن قائمه الارهاب
هل تعتقد ابن حان الوقت لبريطانيا
والاتحاد الاوروبي يعني تفكر في ادراجهم
ضمن قائمه الارهاب خاصه انهم يهددون
المواطنين البريط
اول مشتقين الايرانيين على اراضي بريطانيا
ما شاهدنا
هذه السلوكيات من قبل القياده الايرانيه
وهي غير مقبوله
التسليحيه من الشيعه المسلحه في المنطقه
وتهدد الايرانيين في بريطانيا
ومحاوله تطوير اليورانيوم
بمستوياتي الاسلحه كلها امر غير مقبوله
وقد اوضحنا
معارضتنا كلها تصرفات وقد استجبنا عبر
العقوبات وسبل اخرى ونحن دائما نبقي
الخيارات المفتوحه فيما يخصه اي مداخلات
اخرى نستطيع القيام بها ولكن ايران
وقيادتها يجب ان يدرك بان القرارات التي
يتخذونها كلها هدامه جدا
لمصالح ايران
وما نريد ان نراه هو ايران سلميه تعمل
بشكل سلمي مع جيرانها
ولا تهدد احدا وجمهوريه ناجحه هذا سيسعدنا
جدا ولكن الحاليه غير مقبوله
والتنميه للمملكه المتحده شكرا جزيلا على
كون نشكرك جدا على هذه المقابله شكرا لك
شكرا
في دبي ونترك لكم الكلمه الان
شكرا لزميلنا طلال الحاجه على هذا الحوار
نذهب الى لندن وتبقى معنا المتحدثه باسم
الحكومه البريطانيه روزي دياز مرحبا بك
روزي مضى عام على الحرب روزي كان هناك
تساؤل دائما لماذا كانت تتصدى بيانات
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه والاستخبارات
البريطانيه المشهد الاعلامي في الحديث عن
المعلومات المتعلقه بهذه الحرب البعض يرى
ومن قبل وخاصه من قبل روسيا ان هذا تحريض
على روسيا ببيانات غير دقيقه او صحيحه
نعم شكرا لاستضافتكم الموضع هو واضح الان
تخسر من روسيا الحرب ونستطيع ان نشوف هذا
من خلال مستويات خسائر روسيه على الارض
هذه هي الحرب ليست النجاس الذي تخيله
بوتين بوتين اعتقد انه سيحسم اوكرانيا في
ثلاثه ايام فقط لكن كان على خطا ما فخم
قوه الاوكرانيين او وحده الوحده من
المجتمع الدولي
استعادت القوات الاوكرانيه اكثر من نصف
الارض
التي استولتها روسيا منذ الغزو قبل السنه
بما في ذلك المواقع الاستراتيجيه المهمه
هذه هي الحرب تؤثر على البلدان عبر العالم
ليس
فقط الاقتصاد
الدولي
وكل هذا واضح موافقا للبيانات البريطانيه
ولكن هو السؤال كان لماذا تصدت
الاستخبارات البريطانيه هل كان هناك قرار
سياسي من بريطانيا ان تتصدر نشر البيانات
الخاصه بهذه الحرب من الناحيه العسكريه
[موسيقى]
حتى الان
كنا نريد ان نشوف
انها سلامي الى الصراعة لكن من الواضح انا
بوتين لن يتفاوض طالما يعتقد ان عنده
الخيرات العسكريه
فاذا سمحنا روسيا ان تستمر مع هذا الحرب
بالتاكيد هذا سيؤدي الى اكثر من العنف ضد
المدنيين
وتفاقم الازمه ازمه طاقه والغذا
وتمديد الانكماش الاقتصادي الدولي لهذا
الان بريطانيا وشركائنا الدوليين
يزيدون وطيره المساعده العسكريه
لدعم
واستمرار تقدم الاوكراني على الارض
ولحد قدره روسيا لتستهتف البنيه تحتيها
المعدنيه
المفكر البريطانيه والجهود الدبلوماسيه
تستهقف ان تقلق تغيير حاسم في الصراعات
هناك تصريح منذ قليل لوزير خارجيه
بريطانيا على شاشه العربيه في لقاء مع
زميل طلال الحاج قال في عباره واضحه ان
هناك حق او الصين لديها الحق في ان تقلق
من تزايد الصراع في اوكرانيا ما الذي
تعنيه بريطانيا بهذا الامر هل هي ترى ان
الصين صاحبه حق مشروع في هذه المخاوف وهذا
يعني ان هناك انحياز بريطاني لفكره طرح
الصين للسلام
البري تستمر ان تتابع
ارادت الشعب الاوكراني كنا نريد ان نشوف
السلام
وبالتاكيد الاوكرانيين يريدون ان يشوفوا
هذا السلام اكثر من اي شخص اخر
يجب على اوكرانيا
لتقرر
موقفها من حيث اي مفاوضات مع الصين او مع
البلدان الاخر ليس للبلدان الاخرى خارج
اوكرانيا لان اوكرانيا هي بلد
ديمقراطي ولذلك اوكرانيا
تحتاج الى ان تقرر
مختصره نعم ام لا روزي هل تعتقدين ان خطط
السلام الصينيه او تعتقد الحكومه
البريطانيه ان خطط السلام الصينيه هو خطوه
للامام لانهاء هذا الصراع ام لا نعم ام لا
ليس بسيط مثل هذا
كما قلت
اوكرانيا هي بلدان ديموقراطيه وليس
بريطانيا او اي بلد اخر تستطيع ان تقرر
مستقبل اوكرانيا لها هذا اوكرانيا هي هي
في مقدمه اي مفاوضات واي قرارات حول
المستقبل ولكن الموقف البريطاني يمثل موقف
مبدئي من هذه المبادره جيده ام لا هذا هو
سؤال
كما قلت واعتقد ان الموقفي وموقف الحكومه
البريطانيه هي هو
واضح ندعم الصلاه
[موسيقى]
نحن جاهزين ان
نعتبر
الخطط المختلفه ولكن نركز على السلامه في
اوكرانيا
وقلنا هذا منذ البدايه وفرن روسيا المستوى
وفي البدايه هذه هي الازمه
روزي دياز المتحدثه باسم الحكومه
البريطانيه من لندن
ونبقى معكم مشاهدينا في اطار هذه التغطيه
ولكن بعد فاصل قصير
[موسيقى]
في اعقاب العمليه العسكريه الروسيه على
اوكرانيا اعلى الرئيس الروسي بلاد بوتين
وضع قوات الرضع النوويه في حاله تاهب ومع
دخول الحرب عامها الثاني هل ينفذ بوتين
تهديده ام يغير من استراتيجيته الحربيه
هذا سؤال مطروح
عام منذ ان حرك الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين قوه بلاده باتجاه جارته اوكرانيا
عام برزت فيه سيناريوهات عده لحاضر
ومستقبل هذه الحرب
السيناريو الاسوا والمخاوف الاكبر غربيا
هي الحرب النوويه فما هي اتجاهات روسيا في
عامها الثاني
موسكو من جهه اكدت انها لن تستخدم اسلحه
نوويه الا لحمايه امنها القومي من اي
تهديد وجودي
اما الغرب وعلى راسهم الولايات المتحده
فاخذت تلك التهديدات على محمل الجد محذره
من ان البشريه تواجه للمره الاولى منذ
قرابه خمسه عقود خطر نهايه العالم
مع انه لم تظهر مؤشرات الى تعبئه نوويه
الروسيه الا ان روسيا صعدت عسكريا وسياسيا
ولجات لاستخدام اسلحه فتاكه في معركتها
باوكرانيا الا ان هذه الاسلحه لم تضمن لها
مكاسب سريعه او انتصارا كبيرا وهو ما
يعزوه محللون عسكريون الى استخدام روسيا
اسلحه عفا عنها الزمن مقابل دعم غربي كبير
لاوكرانيا باسلحه ذات قدرات عاليه
وعند التهديد بالنووي اصطدمت روسيا بواقع
انها ليست وحدها من يمتلك السلاح النووي
في المقابل حلف النيتو الداعم الاول
لاوكرانيا يملك ذات الاسلحه
كلما تراجعت انتصارات روسيا في ساحه
المعركه لوحت باستخدام النووي لكنه تهديد
لم ينفذ حتى الان
تلويح تم رفضه ليس فقط من اعداء روسيا
وحدهم بل حتى من حلفائها مثل الصين والهند
لكن هل تبقي موسكو خطتها وتكتيكاتها
الحربيه على الارض كما هي ام ان تحريك
روسيا اسطولا بقدرات نوويه لاول مره منذ
الحرب البارده مؤشر قوي على منحنى جديد قد
تشهده السنه الثانيه للعمليه العسكريه
الروسيه روان حمزه العربيه
وينضم الينا من موسكو المحلل السياسي في
مرحبا بك سيدي مضى عام على هذه الحرب التي
كان يريد منها بوتين ان تكون عمليه عسكريه
سريعه كيف يفكر بوتين في القادم بشان هذه
الحرب هل في مزيد من الصراع والتسلح
والحرب ام سيفكر في السلام
لك مره اخرى وليس هذا المشاهدين اعتقد ان
الرئيس بوتين الان طبعا اول ما يصل اليه
هو تحقيق اهدافه سواء المعلنه في بدايه
العمليه او ما تم الاعلان عنه في وقت لاحق
ولان التطورات اللاحقه بعد بدايه العمليه
غيرت نوعا ما موقف روسيا في التعامل مع
هذه العمليه ومع الازمه الاوكرانيه بشكل
عام الان الهدف الاساسي ربما يتمثل في هذه
المرحله على الاقل في اقامه سيطره الكامله
على منطقه
ضمن حدودها الاداريه والتي تشمل طبعا
هذا الهدف لما يعني ينفذ حتى ولم يتحقر
حتى الان ومن الناحيه السياسيه لان هناك
بالاضافه الى بعد عسكري بعد اخر نقف عند
الهدف العسكري هذا الهدف لم يتحقق حتى
اللحظه ما هي الخطط العسكريه الجديده التي
يمكن ان يلجا اليها بوتين لتحقيق هذا
الهدف
ربما اللجوء الى مختلف الوسائل الاخرى
لتحقيق هذا الهدف
في سعي واضح من القياده العسكريه الروسيه
والتي يتولاها الان رئيس هيئه الاركان
العامه للقوات الروسيه
الحفاظ على ارواح العسكريين الذين يشاركون
في هذه العمليه وهذا يعني توسيع استخدام
المسيرات وربما يعني اسلحه اخرى لن تنعكس
على الخسائر بشكل كبير يعني فيما يتعلق
بتلك المعارك التي تجري الان
على الجانب الاخر عدوه في هذه المعركه
اوكرانيا يحظى بدعم وبمزيد من الدعم كما
هو واضح من قبل امريكا والغرب وهذا ربما
يصعب الموقف من الناحيه العسكريه على
بوتين
لا شك ان روسيا تاخذ مثل هذه الامور
والمزيد من الامدادات الغربيه المقدمه الى
اوكرانيا بعهد الاعتبار وهي مستعده
للتعامل معها سواء عن طريق استخدام ما لم
يتم استخدامه حتى الان من الصواريخ وربما
غيرها من ان يصل الامر الى اسلحه النوويه
ما لم يتم استخدامه حتى اللحظه هذه عباره
مفتوحه
انا لا اعتقد لان كل التلوحات والتلقيحات
الى استخدام الاسلحه النوويه الهدف منها
ربما حصوا الدول الغربيه على القبول
بالمقترحات الروسيه الخاصه بالعوده الى
المفاوضات ولكن انطلاقا مما يحدث الان على
الارض
واخذا بعين الاعتبار تلك المناطق التي
تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه وهي تشكل بعض
التراجعات في البدايه كانت نسبتها 20% من
مجموعه روسيا عازمه بالفعل على اعطاء ذخم
كبير لهذه الحرب في بدايه الربيع القادم
هل ستتوسع عسكريا بالفعل
لا شك ان هناك خطط عسكريه ولكن طبعا هي طي
الكتمان الان لانه بطبيعه الحال هناك عنصر
المفاجئ ربما سواء في الهجوم الذي يمكن
الوقت لصالح من في هذا الصراع البعض يعتقد
ان الوقت ربما يؤدي الى اضعاف موقف بوتين
في الداخل وفي الخارج هل تعتقد ذلك
لا لا اعتقد بان كل الاموال المعلقه على
اداره موقف بوتين وربما اثاره ما يمكن ان
يصبح ثوره ملونه لن يمر في روسيا الى انه
هناك نسبه وعدد عال جدا من المؤيدين
لسياسته حسب المعطيات الاخيره
[موسيقى]
وفي ذكرى مرور عام على الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه تباينت مشاعر المواطنين الروس
بين غضب وحزن وامل بوضع نقطه نهايه لهذه
الحرب
اتوقع وامل ان يكون القادم افضل ما يحدث
في الواقع صعب للغايه ومؤلم لكننا لا نفقد
العزم هناك شعور بالفخر والاستياء والغضب
وهو امر من المستحيل ان نتخلص منه
ولم ارى عائلتي منذ عام لذلك بالنسبه لي
هذا يوم يعكس الما رهيبا ويوم لا اريد
العوده فيه بافكار لاشاهد مره اخرى الصور
ومقاطع الفيديو
والتغطيه مستمره مع حضراتكم في ساعه جديده
بعد هذا الفاصل مع الزميل طاهر بركه
[موسيقى]